tellement elle vous a kiffé elle vous
est donné le blouson défileront et
thématiquement accueilli voilà et je
dois dire que j'ai vu les images en
travaillant les missions avec richard et
on a pris une leçon de journalisme
voici donc maxime gainé dans l'interview
de margot robbie vous allez voir c'est
ce qu'on appelle avoir le sens du
naturel quelle est la chose la plus
déjantée que vous ayez vécu à la fois
par amour ou par amitié
vos personnages dans le film sont mis à
rude épreuve à faire il ya beaucoup
d'action est ce que vous avez fait un
entraînement particulier pour intégrer
ce long métrage vos personnages féminins
sont vraiment badass qu'est-ce que vous
avez particulièrement aimé chez eux
mesdames merci pour cette interview et
d'ailleurs quand je suis venu ici on m'a
donné une mission celle de vous inviter
en personne sur le plateau de touche pas
à mon poste et son animateur aussi
déjanté que harley quinn d'ailleurs une
poussée dehors il vous embrasse tous
parce que bon jour et je vous donne des
invitations piscine une deux ou trois
marie vous ma clé et on y va quand même
aller à londres
ah bonjour la bande annonce à la le film
est très très bien c'est super vraie
réussite
comment aller andré margot robbie parce
que généralement vous retournez voir en
vrai ben elle est juste incroyable aller
vers eux et elle est extrêmement
professionnelle c'est du thé en effet la
seule télé française à avoir les quatre
actrices en même temps donc merci à la
warner nous avoir pillage maintenant
qu'elle a mon numéro elle compte
desquels bien vous avez été de 0,6 à
margot robbie l'attaché de presse merci
à mes séries il va être jaloux c'est
sans tomber sur pire il y avait beaucoup
de travail donc un vrai job c'est bon je
peux dépanner geslin destin